[Musique]
alors soyez la bienvenue les bienvenus à
travers le monde à cette émission de
tam-tam canada en direct de montréal 11
ans on sait le vendredi c'est normal gic
ou comment cette émission qui dure 45
minutes cinquante minutes 55 minutes
nous on n'est pas forcé de s'arrêter
lorsqu'il ya des commerciaux comme ça
qui doit être diffusée nous on n'en
diffuse pas d'abord et aussi on est sur
le web
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'il ya eu
quelques problèmes avec facebook pour la
diffusion en direct donc au moins vous
pouvez nous écouter ça c'est sûr et
certain sur youtube et sur un ca net en
direct est ce que ça fonctionne bien sur
facebook
[Rires]
[Musique]
si jamais ça se défait vous allez sur
youtube où vous allez sur cnet.com en
direct nous sommes présentement vue par
des millions d'yeux où des milliers
d'yeux ça dépend de la formule si vous
êtes un patron c'est des millions si
c'est nous c'est des milliers d'écoutés
au sujet des patrons ils ont renversé la
décision ici à radio canada et aussi
c'est une décision qui a été prise par
d'autres télédiffuseurs la semaine
dernière tout le monde va comprendre de
quoi il s'agit c'est maintenant
autorisée on peut vous faire entendre
ceci on écoute
[Musique]
ça y est
évidemment on peut pas faire ce choix
trop pas parce qu'il y aura des plaintes
mais parce que évidemment sur youtube
c'est dangereux de se faire couper le
signal s'il ya trop de musique qui ne
propriétaire du contenu
j'espère qu'on est encore sur facebook
et youtube nous a pas cassé
on ne peut pas dépasser les seconds
tout va bien fantasque alors c'était la
chanson baby
cette version de mac os bublé le
chanteur canadien avec des enfants alors
c'est maintenant autorisée on peut
ensemble de 1944
si je suis aimé ouais j'avais était
devenu célèbre en raison d'un film qui
avait été produit aux états unis qui
avait remporté l'oscar du meilleur film
saison la chanson la meilleure chanson
originale
c'est un couple un couple américain qui
a écrit cette chanson et c'est un peu
une ode à son l'homme et la femme et je
suis sûr qu'aujourd'hui ces gens là ne
comprendra pas du tout pourquoi
aujourd'hui au site indigné de cette
chanson parce qu'il y avait des
allusions semble y avoir des allusions
dans le contexte aujourd'hui évidemment
du mouvement hashtag base aussi que
l'homme voulait tenter de forcer la
ferme à rester avec lui auprès de lui et
lui verser de l'alcool ne savais pas
trop ce qu'ils avaient dans le vert bon
ce soir maintenant radio-canada cbi
s'est renversée l'addition se disant il
ya eu un tollé de protestations de la
part du public donc on va laisser les
choses où elles sont et c'est maintenant
autorisé les choses intéressantes dans
ça c'est dans le même film où cette
chanson originale a été freinée jouer
les rôles sont inversés plus tard dans
le film c'est vrai donc il ya là une
femme plus tard la fin nous sommes dans
le même film mais personne n'est allé
assez loin pour voir attendait le lieu
deux côtés de madagh bon alors nous vous
savez qu'il ya pas deux côtés de
médailles à 5 images vidéo 5 images pour
devenir le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui tout le monde à la maison
peut jouer mais si les gens nous
regardent en différé ils ont la réponse
bien sûr la question quel est le sujet
aujourd'hui on regarde ça c'est avoir la
bonne réponse vous criez ont fait jouer
avec son nom pad sont aujourd'hui une
fois pharmacie ça pourrait être une
pharmacie sa venue enfin beaucoup de
sens une grosse formation l'automation
l'automation et vous autres des beaux
mots clés et plus encore ajouter des
mots vous allez ajouter des morceaux
comme thématique la 5éme images c'est la
fin des questions au sujet de noël et
voici donc officiellement le thème
aujourd'hui l'automatisation des achats
en magasin avec la robotisation et
intelligence artificielle maryse
champions vous regagnez notre estime et
la bouteille de champagne la finition
versus alors on a un invité spécial
comme à toutes les émissions nous allons
choisir le spécialiste des fois il y en
a plus qu'un mais là aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle a véritablement un
il s'agit de le voici sur skype en
direct des hec montréal professeur
jacques nantel bonjour bonjour bonjour
professeur nantel pour ceux qui ne
savent pas expliquez-nous ce qui est
professeur dentelle maryse mais je pense
qu'il est rattaché à hec montréal c'est
100 abonnés du centre commence bien
spécialiste
- des spécialistes consommation tout ce
qui touche à l'univers de la
consommation marketing c'est ça voila
voila c'est un professeur émérite un des
spécialistes du commerce au détail les
plus souvent cités au canada est
quelqu'un qui est très connu à travers
le monde professeur vous est ce que vous
faites vos emplettes ou vous avez
quelqu'un qui fait ça pour au nom je
défais je les fais mais je voudrais vous
et au talent autant la consommation et
le commerce électronique le marketing en
général ça a été c'est toujours des
sujets qui m'intéressent beaucoup autant
le magasinage comme tel c'est un truc
que j'ai toujours détesté
alors je ne les pose à personne je le
fais moi-même mais je dois dire que je
le fais de façon expéditive
enfin pour moi lorsque le commerce
électronique est arrivée j'ai été un des
premiers à y adhérer et avec beaucoup de
plaisir
est ce que vous êtes passé à travers les
caisses automatiques de wal mart
récemment depuis un an depuis qu'on a
commencé un médecin sur le marché oui
mais je vais peu souvent mais je les ai
essayé en fait visiter pour la première
fois en autriche
carrefour en france en fait bref toutes
les caisses et les les modes
électroniques ce sont des choses que je
vois évoluer déjà depuis plusieurs
années avec beaucoup d'intérêt maryse il
vous quand mettre les cartes sur la
table votre époux travaille dans un
magasin grande surface
tout à fait et savez vous ce qui est
drôle les gens retournent dans ce
magasin parce qu'ils connaissent les
gens et pour eux c'est une expérience ça
devient comme le voisinage alors des
gens arrivent là avec leurs familles
prennent des nouvelles les employés sont
là depuis très longtemps et il adore le
contact humain et j'ai comme
l'impression que ça revient ce contact
humain a besoin du contact humain
absolument absolument mais là où je vous
dirais là où il a une valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire que la caisse de sortie et
pas nécessairement l'endroit où on veut
baisser on veut nécessairement
s'attarder commence à avoir de longues
conversations mais même je voudrais que
si elle déjà qui attendent derrière nous
c'est pas nécessairement meilleur
endroit alors c'est un peu ce qui a
amené
ces changements technologiques il ya
bien d'autres raisons on en parlera dans
un instant mais un une des raisons c'est
que l'on tente et vous avez tout à fait
raison là dessus on tente de mettre de
la valeur là où elles en ont c'est à
dire d'avoir du conseil dans les allées
d'avoir du conseil près du produit pas
nécessairement à la caisse donc
d'alphonse et une réaffectation souvent
d'employés auquel à laquelle on est 6 on
va parler des employés dans un instant
je veux qu'on diffuse la vidéo numéros
deux des missions celle qui lui parle de
warm heart une autre expérience qui a
mené wal mart maintenant que warner qui
fait marche arrière
c'est le fameux musquin ngô et je sais
que le professeur dont elle connaît bien
ça maryse votre vol le magasin où vous
travaillez votre époux ils ont ils ont
du scan and go c'est une voix valence
échec à scotcher cosco d'accord donc ça
c'est chez warner le scan and go et ils
ont annoncé ça en octobre de l'an
dernier et on a appris je sais pas si
c'est grâce à siby si j'ai vu un
reportage là dessus j'ai rien vu
ailleurs qu'il retirait le scanning
hausse à l'exception trois magasins où
il continue l'expérience mais ça ne
fonctionne pas avec le client les
clients n'achètent pas qu'est ce qui se
passe pour faire ça je pense que le m le
maître mot que qu'il faut utiliser ici
c'est le mot expérimentation vous savez
toutes les technologies que l'on voit
émerger maintenant ce sont des
technologies qui en laboratoire
fonctionne très bien mais il faut
l'essayer évidemment contexte réel d'un
coach kanak go c'est c'est une
technologie qui est parfaite à petite
échelle lorsqu'on arrive dans une très
grande surface
généralement ça vient ça vient
interrompre le processus de magasinage
en moins d'avoir vraiment une logique où
on pourra les produits après l'autre de
manière répétitive de ce cargo vient
interrompre le processus de magasinage
il devait raisons pour lesquelles il est
beaucoup moins efficace contrairement
par exemple à un scan en sorte qu'elle
lorsque on note choisi tout ce dont on a
besoin
on l'a dans le panier on lit ce calme on
les met dans un sac puis et on quitte la
notion du cargo arrive un peu trop tôt
dans l'expérience de magasinage
est-ce que la robotisation monsieur
martel pourrait en venir un point ou un
moment donné
on peut afficher des prix de façon
électronique et l'échangé selon l'heure
d'arrivée où leur de magasinage déjà
c'est être con c'est qu'entre 16 heures
et 18 heures il y aura plus de gens
donc on a on affiche des prix de façon
électronique et on va les augmenter
au moment où il ya plus de gens qui font
leurs emplettes bien sûr en fait la
réponse est oui ça existe depuis là
existe depuis déjà longtemps on n'ose
pas l'implanter parce que on ne peut pas
l'écarter parce que ça risque de créer
une certaine commotion les premiers
endroits où cette technologie a été
utilisée de manière expérimentale
tenez vous bien c'est dans les machines
distributrices ou en fonction par
exemple du nombre de barres de chocolat
qu'il reste dans une tribu trice le prix
va augmenter ou en fonction de la
température ambiante les boissons
gazeuses peuvent augmenter s'il fait
très chaud ou 10 minutes prix s'est fait
très froid l inverse évidemment pour les
chocolats chauds ou le café
ce sont des choses qui sont extrêmement
faciles à implanter tout ce dont vous
avez besoin c'est d'avoir machines
distributrices qui est relié au web
donc ça existe existe depuis même très
longtemps on ose prendre les places et
pour des raisons non je pense qu'on peut
l'imaginer assez facile mais c'est le
syndrome d'hubert seuil ou beurre le
sucre à tizi devenu noir d'un trajet en
taxi 2 à 125 dollars le jour de noël
directement
ouais exactement en fait oui oui oui non
vous avez tout à fait raison
une machine distributrice c'est que en
principe lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
demandes par exemple le soir de noël
vous devriez avoir beaucoup de
chauffeurs qui entrent sur la route les
machines peu dur et être et c'est là
peut pas se démultiplier puis peut pas
envoyer quelqu'un à temps réel pour la
remplir aussi rapidement que ce soit moi
j'ai vu dans une petite épicerie de
neige pas loin de ces mois qui s'appelle
je pense adrien abric santé on affiche
des prix mais c'est pas électronique
mais c'est des affiches lumineuses
oui mais le même pot de beurre
d'arachide qui est complètement sans sel
sans ce qui est tout et tout et de
dollars de plus que cher on me jette
white est très cher
ouais mais bon là on parle même poule
oui là vous êtes dans une épicerie plus
spécialisés avec moins de 2 c'est
honnêtement c'est pas que après il va
voir ses débuts the who
vous avez même phénomène chez citron ou
ayant fait ce sont tous des magasins qui
fonctionnent avec moins de volume et
donc avec de plus fortes marges seconde
arrive
ce que je note c'est le prix affiché
avec un numérique là donc ça se change
tout de suite en une bourse et non et
oui ça technologies là vous lève
également de plus en plus en grande
surface dans le domaine de l'accueil
khairi france entre autres au haut
niveau patrick maury je passe les
organes moi j'essaie de penser au pastis
ans avec leur qui peut changer au moment
que moi j'ai dernièrement j'ai acheté
des billets d'avion pour noël
puis je me suis aperçu que en ce moment
où je voulais les acheter et les mamans
je devais acheter une hausse de 20 de la
tipp souviendront de plus je suis en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelle se prépare à
accueillir les étudiants essentiellement
c'est ça existe et ça existe depuis que
l'économie programme en existe c'est
cette idée pas très révolutionnaire en
économique si on avait une information
pure et parfaite en temps réel on
pourrait toujours avoir des débris qui
sont optimaux donc un point de rencontre
entre la fameuse offre et la fameuse
demande
le hic évidemment c'est que tout cela
était théorique à venir jusqu'à il ya
quelques années parce qu'on n'avait
jamais une mesure adéquate en temps réel
maintenant on l'a en fait je même aller
plus loin
le prix apparemment augmenté sur notre
billet d'avion de la première fois et la
deuxième fois que vous êtes allé parce
que vous même ne fait que vous ne l'ayez
pas acheter mais que vous y soyez
retourner nous donner un signal de
marché moi j'aimerais revenir sur
sur quoi on avait quoi on a commencé
l'entrevue c'est qu'on parlait donc oui
le contact humain c'est important puis
vous disiez que vous ça serait mieux que
le contact humain soit près des produits
et non à la caisse mais moi je trouve
que la caisse est justement l'endroit on
est le plus insécure c'est notre argent
qui est en jeu puis on compte nous scène
on a vraiment besoin d'être sécurisée
est sûr qu'on qu'on a la bonne étiquette
parce que déjà je trouve que dans les
allées ça demande tellement être
doctorat pour comprendre les spéciaux
c'est toi ou pour 2,3 pour que 5 20% de
réduction mais déjà je trouve qu'ils
rentrent ça tellement compliqué pour
qu'on sache exactement
oui par contre c'est très bon non
seulement même dalle arabe et va être
perçue puis moi je trouve que c'est
quand même important d'avoir quelqu'un
qui te donne ma note tape sur l'époque
dit madame je vous ai dit je sais pas si
les déconseiller
qu'est ce que vous en pensez bah écoutez
je peux pas aujourd'hui ce qu'on vient
pas au con air mais faut bien comprendre
que touche à ça se passe dans un milieu
où les marges de profit sont le coup
croyez le ou non mais sur de plus en
plus petit la concurrence est très forte
je pense que dans les temps de bien
informer si je prends le domaine de
l'alimentation les marges de profit net
mais n'en sont littéralement commence à
glisser en bas de 1% pas bruno minettes
de brut en taborea 18%
ça veut dire cas par exemple dans la
conserve de soupe que vous achetez de
kembo vous l'achetez peut-être un dollar
vous allez la revendre
neuf mille fois que les pays les commits
l'électricité le magasin est en fait
trop chaud il va vous resté grosso modo
à peu près 1,1 sous 2 profite donc de
voir beaucoup de volume la façon d'y
arriver c'est évidemment d'avoir une
version de ces cookies extrêmement serré
et évidemment les le coup de main
d'oeuvre qui comptent pour beaucoup il
faut comprendre que le secteur de
l'alimentation notamment en grande
surface plus précisément ce sont
vraiment les tropiques est compliqué
sierre luchetti ce sont des emplois au
salaire minimum le salaire minimum vous
avez une rotation personnel dans
l'alimentation est de 100 % par année de
ma vie la réalité sauf exception là
c'est que le caissier ou la cacher que
vous allez voir on a appris du loup en
mars où leur père et plus bas en mars
suivant il aurait déjà changé parce que
il sera il y aura migré sur un autre
emploi au canada en est en période de
plein emploi donc les hommes à trouver
des gens qui sont prêts à faire cet
emploi là à 12 dollars et qui vont
rester 4,5 impôts que puissiez leur
présenter vos enfants où ils vont tous à
vos petits-enfants
c'est un monde idéal mais ça se voit de
moins en moins mais c'est intéressant
parce que ça revient au point dont je
parlais tantôt chez les cosco où on
n'entre pas permis même où il ya des
gens qui sont là depuis 30 1 qui gagnent
très bien leur vie et qui sont
multitâches
ce sont des endroits qui sont très
efficaces oui vous avez raison ils sont
reçus en vrac sont très efficaces mais
il faut bien comprendre par contre que
cosco une des très grande partie de ses
revenus c'est la carte d'abonnement
alors évidemment ça ça ça change la
donne
vous avez peur vous avez tort monsieur
est même tout le monde
si si demain vous voulez avoir le modèle
il faudrait que 126 jean coutu est
également une carte d'abonnement à 56
dollar ou à 120 130 dollars par année
selon la catégorie
que vous ayez la même chose également
chez métro la même chose chez rona la
même chose dans tous les magasins bell
on randonne syndrome d'être flic toute
évidence était remplie je peux pas
m'abonner à tous puis être capable de
fonctionner qu un budget limité mais
j'imagine dans le recours à la pilule
ouais mais vous êtes au courant qu'elle
avait de l'année les gens reçoivent six
ont fait des achats
ils ont un pourcentage ça fonctionne
davantage comme une coopérative
jusqu'aux cas ce qu a eu le génie d'y
penser les premiers aujourd'hui ce
modèle
honnêtement il serait difficile à
démultiplier ça ressemble davantage à un
culte on s'entend des questions aussi
c'est quoi l'impact sur la société sur
l'économie en général si on remplace des
milliers de caissiers caissières des
chauffeurs de taxi des chauffeurs de vie
pas si on les remplace par des machines
parce que ce sont des quand même des
gens qui qu'ils dépensent pour d'autres
choses dans la société qui paye le texte
c'est racines sont sans emploi qu'est ce
qui arrive
la gueule aussi d'excellentes questions
que les aliments va chuter les moins de
commandes
pas vraiment non posez-les excellente
question c'est une question qui si on
poussait son épouse à peine lorsqu'on
posait cette question le ya cinq ans au
moment où vous aviez un taux de chômage
et aux environs de 6% à la question aux
est elle se posera peut-être dans cinq
ou six ans dont c'est une question qu'on
ne peut pas occulter
donc je reviens dans un instant mais au
moment où on se parle
la question ne se pose à tout le moins
en amérique du nord et en europe
parce que on est en situation de plein
emploi donc remplacer la sorte 15 par un
robot honnêtement ça crée une peau
beaucoup beaucoup de chômage parce que
en fait celle inverse on a des
difficultés à recruter et à retenir de
cet employé de façon générale sauf
exception
maintenant si on retombe dans une
situation de précarité d'emploi de la
question se pose maintenant je vous
dirais que ça demeure quand même que ce
sont des emplois qui sont pas
particulièrement intéressants s'ils
peuvent être remplacés par des emplois
influent dans la région
d'où mon exemple du début se dire mais
si vous voulez favoriser le contact
humain même c'est peut-être peau dans la
caisse dont vous en avez besoin c'est
peut-être ailleurs mais l'autre question
c'est que les positions comme ça qui est
ici et qui ciel c'était là sont souvent
des emplois d'entrée ou des emplois
importants pour des étudiants ou les
retraités qui ont besoin d'un peu
d'argent ou un peu d'expérience pour
commencer leur carrière au travail
si les emplois ne sont pas là qu'est ce
qu'ils font mais je pense que ce n'est
pas tant
comprendre que c'est pas un ou l'autre
ça peut être un élan mais ça peut être
un qui est modifié une condition
actuelle vous avez mentionné les
retraités les retraités c'est un bon
exemple
parce que le secteur de la quincaillerie
est un secteur qui emploie beaucoup de
retraités mais on n est pas au 15e
justement on les met dans les allées
parce que c'est eux qui sont en mesure
de donner des conseils sur la façon de
faire une jonction électrique par
exemple vous avez besoin de mareth vous
avez besoin de fil il devait également
besoin deux fois ci si vous avez oublié
ça c'est pas la cas est qu'on voit en
mesure de vous le dire
surtout si élevé de personnes qui
attendent derrière boucle donc
l'utilisation des retraités est un bon
exemple de l'utilisation adéquate de ce
genre de tels les étudiants ça c'est
autre chose
vous avez raison que les étudiants se
sont d d d emplois qui sont précaires
qui ils sont pas les emplois très grande
valeur ajoutée
ce sont des emplois qui sont
extraordinaires pour des étudiants mais
à cet égard les étudiants eux mêmes en
ce moment son temps après 2010 perd
nombreux types d'emplois je veux vous
dire par expérience que vous recrutez
des étudiants pour des tâches comme
celle là honnêtement ils vont voir que
vous le ville de bonheur parce que ces
mêmes étudiants aujourd'hui sont
sollicités pour des emplois avec une
valeur plus grands j'avais une question
parce que maintenant on voit comme par
exemple chez calendar ou encore dans
certains endroits on nous fait passer
par des longues files où l'on nous
expose à des produits avant qu'on puisse
passer à la caisse et laurence fehlmann
titre ce phénomène là s'installer un peu
partout pourquoi j'imagine on veut faire
de l'argent en faisant des trucs avec
une marge de profit plus importante
raison mais ça date pas d'hier ça date
pas d'hier c'est ce qu'on appelle la
gestion ni bouder ou des 17 caisses 1-1
qui kills qui le raconte de manière
absolument extraordinaire c'est jean
coutu lui même le père lorsque jacques
où tu parles de la façon dont il a conçu
ses magasins dans les années 70 c'est
formidable à entendre jean coutu zealand
de son côté pas d'argent que les
médicaments ce qui risque était
rigoureusement vrai aujourd'hui c'est
plus calme mais à l'époque c'était vrai
donc moi je m'emploie y est à mettre des
sacs de tupi des petits gâteaux dans des
dribbles des ziani très très très
étroite
lorsqu'on s'en allait à la caisse de
façon à ce que dis-je gens à pass à
l'enfant fasse tomber quelques uns et
soient gênés dé remettre sur la table
est donc les mettait dans leur panier
soit celle là je sais pas couture dont
vous avez raison ça date pas d'hier
qu'est ce qu'on essaie de faire avec ça
trois choses la première c'est que on
essaie de faire patienter les gens
lorsque des sorties qu'elles sont
longues
vous parlez de comédiens tahar yeux
c'est effectivement souvent le cas c'est
également le cas chez huawei lorsque les
sortes qu'elles sont longues
ben vous avez un avantage à mettre des
produits autour d'eux surtout si si il
s'en produit acheté ça les occupe la
deuxième chose c'est que vous avez
beaucoup de produits que vous allez
retrouver la pro tous mais beaucoup qui
sont des produits que l'on que l'on
n'oublie constamment d'acheter et pour
lesquelles on doit retourner je pense
entre autres aux fameuses pile
électrique lorsque vous allez chez kelly
détail où on à être toujours là parce
que c'est s'est produit pendant à ses
dreads j'en ai besoin
et puis la troisième chose c'est vous
allez avoir des produits d'appel des
produits colorés des produits pour les
autres y aller avec des enfants
demain ils vont les mettre dans votre
panier est ce que ces produits longs de
plus grandes marges
pas nécessairement mais ces produits-là
génère beaucoup de ses fils l'a pas fait
au lieu d'avoir dix 10 lignes qui
attendent après 10 10 10 15 il ya une
ligne pour dick à skis ça ne se donne
l'impression d'avancer plus rapidement
parce que ça sert pour moi c'est
spécifiquement parce que moi quand je
mets dedans sont-ils d'attentes devants
5-1 c'est sûr que c'est la plains tous
les autres passe-droits
je suis content mais c'est intéressant
ce que vous devez parce que voyez-vous
cette notion de temps d'attentes
ça illustre bien effectivement la
gestion du personnel de sorte qu'un
c'est un truc qui est qui et qui pis est
difficile on n'a pas toujours
on n'a pas toujours les les employés en
nombre suffisant et soit en passant une
des raisons pour laquelle les sorties de
caisse ont été automatisées notamment en
europe par contre je pense au groupe
metro pas le nommer le groupe allemand
et carrefour c'est simplement pour
accélérer la sortie pas falloir
accélérer votre sortie de caisse en face
à nous on refait des expressions ici
merci beaucoup professeurs nous avons
parlé de ses habitudes de consommation
ici même au canada alors et puis
espérons que vous avez terminé vos
achats vous centrez pendant trop
d'années
d'ici quelques jours c'est fait et si
c'est pas fait de votre côté vous
souhaite un bon magazine
moi j'ai pas beaucoup d'amis avez vous
oublié les bottes démission il ya 100
points à perdre chaque semaine ou à
notre jeu de la grosse boule et on ça va
débouler les choses on va t'amuser
l'éclairage pour bien se mettre dans le
dans le créneau
d'abord la première question c'est pour
vérifier si vous avez bien écouter cette
entrevue avec le professeur dentelle
d'accord on vérifie si les étudiants
étaient à l'écouté pendant le cours
professeur nantel jacques nantel
professeur de marketing à hec montréal
première question que les détaillants au
canada continue expérimenté ça c'est
préambule c'est comme question
référendaire
le détaillant au canada continue et
expérimenté en magasin avec l'automation
des achats pour leurs consommateurs afin
de voir ce qui plaît ou qui ne plaît pas
à la clientèle dans les magasins walmart
voici la question quels outils robotisés
ou artificiellement intelligent annoncé
en grande pompe durant la dernière année
a fait l'objet d'un rappel et retiré par
les clients car ils n'en veulent pas
attention il ya un choix de réponses
soient pas vous allez répondre le
dernier a alors c'est son service de
livraison en magasin en 24 heures
d'articles commandés en ligne par les
clients qui a été retranché
mais ce sont ses caisses enregistreuses
sans caissier et sans argent comptant ou
est ce que c'est c'est son outil scan
and go qui additionnent votre facture au
fur
jure que vous mettez les articles dans
votre chariot jusqu'à 1 go c'est la ccc
pas assez c'est très bien c'est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pousser un accord non
moi aussi je vais avec ses 7 à fixer en
fait moi je juge poupée méchaal est
cassé
je sais que vous avez là c'était c'était
marqué à son malice mais je change et
donc vous avez tous pas perdu 20 je vous
ai dit que les choses allaient déboulé
voici maintenant notre on est tous cas
ce qu'on y fait pendant le deuxième jeu
je pense que oui voici le deuxième jeu
de la grosse boule temps points à perdre
cette fois-ci vous êtes tous à 100 pour
le moment
30 points à perdre voici je pense qu a
également appris en lui si vous voulez
acheter un magasin produit autre qu'une
denrée alimentaire qui est un
authentique produit canadien
attendez à quel autocollants statique
pouvez-vous véritablement vous fier ou
faire confiance je répète c'est acheter
un produit là en magasin et voulaient
être sûrs que c'est vraiment un produit
canadien 1
à quel genre d'auto collants parce qu'on
met des autocollants c'est quoi est-ce
que c'est un fabriqués au canada
ça vous pouvez y aller en pleine
confiance à ce que ces bébés fait au
canada où est-ce que c'est s'est produit
au canada
à quelle auto collants mais le colloque
il dit que votre produit vraiment
canadien fabriqués au canada à b fait au
canada où s'est produit au canada samedi
qui fabrique et c'est à ce tour on a
chez vous s'est produit au calme
c'est toujours c'est chez vous partout
au canada c'est en effet au canada made
in canada moi je préférais avec avec
fait au canada fait au canada donc je
sais que deux d'entre vous allez perdre
point g sont les mots en joue sans les
mots n'a vraiment alors la barre et
panser ses produits au canada
l'applaudît elles gagnent tous ces
points vous perdez 30 chacun alors la
différence oui entre fait au canada il
produit canada si vous voyez un produit
avec un auteur un autocollant qui dit
produits au canada
ça veut dire que se produit un seuil de
contenu canadien plus élevé 90 % tandis
que fait au canada ou fabriqués au
canada veut dire qu au moins 51% des
coûts directs de production de
fabrication étaient engagés au canada
c'est beaucoup plus que l'on a c'est
donc fier vous un produit au canada
produit au canada producing canada pour
les anglais pour les plus copains le
mark
alors écoutez on veut faire disposant le
dernier concours avant le dernier jeu la
grosse boule
je voulais vous on connaît en ligne est
ce qu'il ya une vidéo qu'on devrait
absolument montrer attend dé voir venez
voir savez notre catégorie qui s'appelle
pas mon meilleur coup mais chercher dans
nos archives
ouais sur le sur la page web de tam-tam
canada à quoi voici à quoi ça ressemble
cette semaine pour se font dire la
question qu'on a développée avec le pro
façon dentelle il ya un achat de noël
coup de main un peu gauche des robots un
magasin donc on en reparle
google goog j ai payé google veut avoir
une commission pour les achats sur
internet dont vous allez sur google vous
finissez par acheté dans un magasin
parce que vous êtes passé par google
google réclame donc ils font rien mais
ils veulent de l'argent qu'ils veulent
tous et ccc leucémie ou encore trucs et
attrapes dh en ligne au canada
attention vous voyez une aubaine ou
pense est une aubaine ce ne n'est pas
véritablement c'est vraiment tourné dans
la consommation il ya aussi la
consommation responsable
l'antidote du ventre mou pour ceux qui
veulent pas consommer à noël qui n'ont
pas d'amis comme on les appelle en
anglais le black friday
ouais mais c'est une tradition
américaine qui a traversé la frontière
pour devenir aussi ici au canada avant
qu'on
on voit qui a gagné qui a perdu
aujourd'hui au halo rouge de l'émission
je voulais quand je conte joue à la
fameuse quelle est l'image de la semaine
vous prêts
quelle image la semaine je réponds pas
ou par non à vos questions présentes à
la mare images de soudain entonnant vous
devez deviner quelle est l'image cette
semaine personne ici en studio ne sais
où je réponds oui ou par non à vos
questions et l'image de la semaine est
ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ça est ce
qu'on est en droit de poser des
questions est oui pour soi que je répond
par oui ou par non
ce que ça monsieur barbu blanc avait
cheveux barbe blanche
monsieur blanc là dedans oui je m'en
excuse mais je pense pas l'image no spam
est-ce que ça concerne l'économie la
politique et ça pourrait consommer
l'économie les politiques je répondrais
oui à cette question
marc et noir c'est un politicien
non ce n'est pas un politicien non non
ce n'est pas un politicien
est ce que c'est un exécutif exécutive
d'une compagnie un chinois
ça pourrait être ça ça pourrait être ça
mais c'est pas tout à fait juste
est ce que c'est un canadien avaient
certes en canard 700 canadiens enlevés
aux enchères après allergènes mon dieu
vous brûlez vous brûler ça pourrait être
ça mais c'est pas seulement ça vous
d'eux avait la bonne réponse en présente
la vidéo et on regarde c'est quoi
l'image la semaine je les composent et
moi-même à partir de trois images vues
dans les médias cette semaine
donc voilà on le veut on révèle les deux
otages canadiens en chine et j'en parle
de deux auteurs des mois c'est pas des
otages sont des légendes et des coûts
deux détenus enchaînés
le journal le monde a parlé d' otages
mais moi je crois que c'est quand même
la faux pas et c'est là détenue ou
allait plus détenu faut faire attention
à bien d'être relâché et les patients
sous consolation au canada
donc oui ils sont mignons petits
problèmes entre la chine et le canada
july wenzhou
voilà donc je pensais c'était réglé
la faute au delà de l'anpaa de l'année
pas encore mais de la semaine
certainement dans les stations haut
avez vous reçu le mémo c'est à nouveau
un nouveau un nouveau segment des
missions avez vous reçu non celle des
pavés cuisine vient d'où viennent les
mots et vient de votre patron qui le
regarde sur qui doit vous en parler ce
n'est pas lui le mémo avait voulu mais
le mot lemay beau j'ai vu ça lundi matin
c'était au sujet d'une nouvelle
application disponible pour écouter nos
émissions la crise
l'application vous rend l'application
est bien sûr ça fait deux semaines qu'on
a pas bien on m en parler une vidéo pour
alors le mémo qu'est-ce qui disait le
patron monde mais moi c'est toi que
c'est ce que je me suis un peu timide ou
si vous l'avez vous lui même ou bien que
l'application est vraiment pratique il
faut absolument la télécharger le plus
rapidement possible d'un beau téléphone
je les regardais rapidement à ce que je
sais c'est que c'est possible de
télécharger
voilà sur les téléphones apple ou
android c'est ça oui ça faisait partie
du mémo fantastique et il disait dans le
mémo que 6377 personnes avaient
téléchargé seulement du côté français
cette nouvelle application pour les très
populaires du côté français est très
pratique et extra jeudi j'ai été surpris
dans les chiffres
oui c'est très agréable de lire de
consulter une nouvelle sur le
sollicitent sur l'application que l'on
fait une démonstration à vous l'avait
déjà montré were commencer bien sûr si
vous allez sur notre site vous allez
voir cette image là sur en marge à
droite
et puis vous pouvez cliquer dessus ça va
vous la langue de votre choix
ouais et puis voilà ça va vous envoyer
vers en fait google sait où
apostol ouais mais là on est sur leur
dynamique voilà vous choisissez ouais
bon les gens l'ont déjà vu donc ça qui
est intéressant c'est lorsque vous
ouvrez votre téléphone vous pouvez
mettre pour la rci applications et
lorsque vous cliquez dessus
il se remet à jour il ouvre sur la
dernière page et là vous attendez
rapidement se remettre à jour à la
journée même où vous l'utilisez avons
donc vous vous êtes vous même une
nouvelle cliente de rci ne te presser en
application oui mais je pense que c'est
génial c'est vraiment génial pour tous
les gens je leur ai écouté mes trucs
qu'on fait c'est tout à fait intéressant
donc vous aviez pas besoin du mémo vous
vous êtes une analyse orly adapteur donc
une personne qui adopte tous très
rapidement c'est fantastique
alors personne qui gobent tout très
rapidement ce projet c'est un synonyme
de bon une fois attention c'est pas ton
est à l'écouté il regarde en plus de sa
3e jeu de la grosse boule combien de
points à perdre
55 ans pointait à petit c'est 52e qui a
tous ses points jusqu'à maintenant mois
seulement elle nous on est à 80
troisième jeu au sujet du commerce
électronique les canadiens semblent
avoir véritablement intégré cette
nouvelle façon de consommer au quotidien
avec près de 23 jours il a 23 millions
canadiens qui ont utilisé cette année le
web pour acheter au moins un produit et
service d'accord il ya 37 millions de
canadiens 36 millions 23 millions
d'entre eux ont déjà acheté sur le web
les autres sont des enfants qui n'ont
pas encore leur compte alors à la clé
pourcentage de tous les achats de tous
le montant total de tous les achats on a
combien d'argent juste pendant l'année
millions de dollars en milliards de
dollars
toutes les dépenses des canadiens
pourcentage acheter pour acheter des
produits et des services
quel est le pourcentage qui a été acheté
cette année vient le web le les outils
électroniques est ce que ca 6 % de
toutes les dépenses qui ont été engagées
grâce aux outils électroniques
est ce que ces bébés 8% pas beaucoup de
gens qui ne s'aiment pas est ce que c
'est 18% maintenant de tout de tout et
dépenses
ou est-ce que ces 26 % c'est une part de
matt aux demandes manteau un gros gâteau
et on a quatre réponses oui oui où
aucune de ces réponses étaient vraiment
bonnes questions
8 18% très bien c'est 8% mais je pense
que moi je vais m'essayer à 26 teint 18%
28% plus pour cent je pense qu on a au
moins deux d'entre vous qui allez perdre
des points
la bonne réponse est oui pour sa dette à
70 vous êtes 50 et vous êtes toujours ça
c'était vous je vais partager le
champagne mais voilà c'est tout c'est
tellement ensemble c'est ce soir je
pense qu'on en est maintenant rendu
vendredi soir ici alors demanderait
alors c'est tout un pur 7
j'allais dire cette saison de tam tam en
fait cette année pourtant le canada avec
moi la semaine prochaine j'aimerais me 6
g par semaine et ce n'est mort là non
plus on vous souhaiter joyeux noël parce
que vous partez web on en français ou en
anglais non sauf en france
noël le mot noël mais pas les equity
écoute et quand on joue pas les paroles
[Musique]
cette caméra avec le thème de fermeture
officielle de l'émission
[Musique]
où